there are only a few things you need to
do to win and the way you do it is
entirely up to you which is why I love
boiling things down to just like what
are the few things that everything has
in common and everything else's
preference we could feel amazing about
it we can feel terrible about it we can
feel neutral about it but all that will
matter is what Behavior we change in
order to increase the likelihood that we
do what we want next time I always said
I was going to do this thing observation
I did not do it what is the change in my
behavior or my environment that I'm
going to do next time to increase the
likelihood that I do it